كان يستدرج وضحاياه بواسطه مواقع التعارف
على الانترنت
اقنعهن بانه يمكن الوثوق به لانه ضابط
شرطه ثم اعتدى عليهن واغتصبهن
الاسميه انجليزيه التهمه اغتصاب وتحرش
وعنف منزلي
هكذا كان الضابط في شرطه لندن
يرى نفسه بينما كان يتفنن في اهانه ضحاياه
وسخريه منهن ارتكبت 94 جريمه خلال 17 عاما
منها 420 جريمه اغتصاب اثنتي عشره امراه
استغل كارت منصبه لاغراء الضحايا ثم
استدرجهن لمنزله وتحرش بهم اغتصبهن وعنفهن
ابقى هنا لساعات دون طعام اجبر بعضهن على
تنظيف المنزل وهم عاريات ووصفهن بالسمينات
والكساله تحكم فيما كنا يلبسنا وياكلنا
واين ينامنا عزلنا عما
يحدثنا من التحدث الى اطفاله او الى رجال
اخرين
شرعا تارك في ارتكاب جرائمه قبل عقدين من
الزمان تحديدا
2003 وظل مستمرا في فعله حتى عام 2020 كان
يحذر الضحايا من انه اذا فكرنا بالتحدث
فان احدا لن يصدقن لانه ضابط شرطه خدم
مكان في الجيش انضم الى شرطه لندن عام
2001 وبعد ثمان سنوات تم الترقيته الى
ضابط مسلح في قياده الحمايه البرلمانيه
والدبلوماسيه المتخصصه
وفي ظل قيود صارمه وبعد اكثر من عام من
جلسات استماع ما قبل المحاكمه اقر كرك في
كانون الثاني عام 2023 بالذنب في التهم
الست الاخيره بعد حوالي شهر على اقراره
بالذنب في ثلاث واربعين تهمه اخرى
طيب طيب
قدمت ضدها المجرم
استاذ ستيرنج
كونجو
ترامب
وتستمر
جرائم الجنسيه التاريخ الاجرام الحديث في
المملكه المتحده